I'm so hungry.
"Cream fresh," or "crËme fraÓche"?
Hey! Where's the new guy? We are starving.
I know, I'm sorry, John's running late,
but he'll be here.
Is that a blue streak in your hair?
Yeah, you like it? Looks good, right?
Uh-oh, it's happening.
What is happening?
Oh Robbie, we love you, but you always do this
Do what?
Oh, you morph into the guys that you date.
That's...not true, come on.
I...
What? It happened, like, once.
Okay, fine, that was old me,
but...this is new Robyn, so.
Remember when you dated Spencer?
Oh, come on. You guys, no.
He used to barbecue bread.
Can you put that away--
I have that photo.
Hold up, hold up.
Remember that barbecue dinner?
It was a weak moment.
Say "nice rack."
Nice rack!
You know what'd make this brisket sandwich
even better?
French fries?
Oh, I love a good deep-fried tater,
but I was thinking meat patties.
Oh.
For the bun.
Yeah.
Instead of the bread.
With like, chicken-y sprinkles, right?
You know exactly what I'm talkin' about.
Yeah, I got you, baby.
So what?
You're a vegetarian.
I eat fish sometimes.
Oh-oh-oh, Robyn.
Come on, it's not that bad.
It could have been worse.
Yeah, like Banyan, the artiste?
Oh yeah, that vase.
It's a vase, why is that so weird?
Oh yeah, I got it.
Happy birthday, Todd.
Cool. So it's like a bunch of your gum?
It's a vase.
Oh...
You know, because I'm sculpting now.
Well, it's not just a vase,
it's a piece of her soul.
I dig it.
Well...I can't wait for my birthday.
I'll make you one.
Oh man. Yeah--no, thanks. Thanks, Banyan.
It's actually pronounced Ban-YAN.
-Yeah. -Mm-hm. That's what I said.
It's like an emphasis on the end of it.
Ban-YAN.
BanYAN.
BanYAN. "I am not artist, I'm an artiste."
Okay, but he was the worst one.
No.
Yes, he was.
No, no!
Yes he was!
The worst one was the health fanatic.
Kevin?
Kevin...
Yeah, I have that photo.
Okay, you know what? This is kind of unfair.
What is this, pick on Robyn day? Come on.
So, I'm just trying to help Robyn
unlock her true potential.
It's baby steps.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is the same Robyn who refused to come
to my apartment
because I lived on the fifth floor walk-up?
You had a weird roommate.
Remember that silly, weird guy.
You should show everyone the move we were
working on earlier.
Uh--You know, that's just--It's late, everybody's
so tired.
Come on.
No, I'm-I'm awake for that.
Okay.
Focus on form, focus on form.
Full cardio comfort, you got it, babe.
Push!
Lock out, lock out.
Ah! This is what living feels like.
Do you want your juice?
No.
Guys, I was on the ground for 30 minutes.
It was the worst--
Thirty-seven minutes.
Hey, hi.
Hi!
Sorry I'm late, everyone.
Mimosas on me.
No!
Oh!
You don't have to--No, don't.
No, no, no, let him do it.
Let the man do it.
No, no, it's fine.
Hey, so this is Lucy, Benjamin, Milo, and
Todd.
It is great to meet everyone.
This is awesome.
Me too.
Yeah.
Hey, your hair! You did it.
Yeah!
Oh, you look so good, you look great.
I could never do that.
Well, you know, it's just a Robyn thing to
do.
Yup.
Okay, let's order.
Is French toast too naughty?